welcome to this video playing the
fighting dragon from from from Germany
international master to try to play in a
touch Leningrad style stand naming them
pursed young cutco now don't know him I
mean I know the name but I don't know
him as some I don't know him from face
to face okay I'll play I'm the set up
with the exchange on e4 and e5 it some
some things that was some recommended in
a book by grandmaster and [ __ ] on kindle
money he wrote a book about the landing
where a Dutch couple of years ago and I
liked the book I got it out of curiosity
not really intending to play the
Leningrad Dutch but it it was a very
nice it was very nicely explained in the
book and I played a couple of games with
the Leningrad touch not without success
but I am at the entire decided to to not
make this permanent mainstay of my
opening repertoire preferring more solid
openings okay so what is this it's a
complicated position of course this is
typical for the for the Dutch lending
rate or the Dutch in general it leads to
complicated claim it's not often leading
to good play for black but it's always
it's always interesting and double-edged
this is what makes the Dutch defense an
interesting opening to play
okay so maybe I just take him g4
surprise me that seems to weaken the e5
square so that I maybe have found the
opportunity to put a piece down 94 I
don't really believe as good he takes
cream cakes i can play g5 I think just
Bishop f4 just Bishop f4 looks like a
normal and good way to play
you
yep simple and good what now I'm not
sure he now threatens to take it on d
497 this move i'd like to play but
there's g6 hanging and this is really
hanging it's nothing I can play as a
sacrifice maybe I can go but should be
six first and somehow we lie on tactics
yeah I think I can do that now it takes
it takes Queen takes I have no gee 190
five looks um yeah this looks
threatening enough so that he doesn't
people he won't take it I guess and
maybe I'm winning a move here when you
tempo attacking c4b three years the the
normal looking move now
mmm now that said didn't expect him if I
take I take with the bishop my lights
class on our problem okay but at least
I've got strong control of the dark
squares and as a compensation
yeah maybe he can play Knight him when I
194 have Bishop see huh uh huh well this
one I didn't expect
hmm yeah still I cannot gunite these
happen because these six hangs
98 is just a very unattractive move
check maybe this wave
yeah this looks it looks a very
artificial yeah but difficult to do
something else after I took only two
Queen takes Knight eggs is my idea
gaining a temper won't be too
hmm yeah that's not very attractive
however the endgame here shouldn't be
too bad for me this this looks playable
if we get rocks off
yeah this is ok now this is ok now it's
not great but should be should be
something you can you can know who'd he
will play g5 problem
ok
yeah actually wanted tonight yourself
okay right it's not it's not a big kid
because shame
it's just a passer firm way to play I
know but what else that did not
wow how uncomfortable is this well ugly
just really ugly just check
my G some nights and some not great yeah
you can simply just just hang around and
do nothing I like it can take it no no
what the heck did i do I completely
forgot that you can take it Wow
time warning ah what the heck I'm such
an idiot it was just a draw I mean it
was it was ugly but it was a draw check
check now the way he's playing at its
ardila draw check check white forfeits
50 faded on time didn't you know I
didn't even see that I'm ahead on the
clock I was down on the clock all the
time yeah like here I was down in the
clock all the time I was just making
some automatic moves yeah okay money to
one survived Iran you are lucky with the
clock of course him yeah I didn't really
see that I was that on the clock
otherwise I would have maybe offered to
draw but I didn't really have the time
for that didn't didn't see ah what an
idiotic way to to to make a loss all of
this I just I mean it's luck it's an oak
position yeah but still I think it's
it's it's um something that black should
hold a night f5 justjust blunders it
away in one move now it was a very
uncomfortable position the real problem
was 11 problem was that right here this
should I hear about him I took only two
went after Queen each other's always
Queenie 6 and this Queenie ate what I
intended
it wasn't term wasn't really wasn't
really helping my position check I need
to do something else here grab the
computer place 97 the move black wants
to play and it finds yeah this is good
this check Queen takes and Queen B 6
yeah okay for computer line technically
working against him and here maybe yeah
what I did checking and this was just
leading to a big problem can I can also
go here this is also better than in the
game just not giving him all the time
here with Queenie to yeah it was a bad
end game which I think I hold then I
have pretty much accidentally one on
time I know there will be people writing
are you play on time and so I just I
just didn't see that I was ahead on the
clock and I really don't don't care
thanks for watching